so da war
mal gucken was es da heute zu sehen gibt und ihr müsst mich dran erinnern dass ich wieder den
chat ausblende vielleicht hätte ich mir was zu trinken holen sollen vorher
jetzt noch keiner da doch jetzt jetzt in die ersten da
vor discord notify ich glaube mod checken musste nicht da ist auch keiner da
so das ganze geht wohl angeblich um 19 Uhr los ich bin mal gespannt was sie zeigen werden
letzten jahre war ja immer hardcore langweilig
schauen wir mal ich bin gespannt also man muss übrigens hier gucken auf dem offiziellen
channel habe ich gelesen weil da würden sie sogar die mca music ausfiltern aus dem stream
gucken wir mal was da ich kann das wort immer mal schreiben alle prediction prediction was
es da gibt fünf predictions von äußerst vertrauenswürdigen seiten predictions
wer prediktet da was prediktion ja übrigens ich habe letztens eine radio gehört für haltet
euch fest elektro dick das ist auch ziemlich erfällnahme im jahr 2021
was ist das was was zum wie geht es wie geht es weg
monka wie
ah was ist das denn
rechts auf das ne ist immer noch da ist immer noch da add to my channel ihr könnt mir nein
ok moment moment ffz ffz to the rescue hier extension overlay man kann auch den mist ausschalten
show overlay extensions never never alda never jetzt ist weg beste get schrecked extensions
f weg sind sie richtig heckermann tactic wieder ja ich weiß ja ich bin halt manchmal dann
doch nicht so alt wie es auf dem papier steht ne ist der animierte kick schon rally ne du
bist gehyped ich weiß noch nicht so genau ich meine ich kenne den battlefield trailer
schon und was dann ansonsten so bei der xbox kommt ja ja mal gucken schau mal mal bf3 4
ist heute verrückt echt jetzt zeigt mal her bettel log bf3 das muss ich jetzt mal überprüfen
multiplayer ich hoffe die bringen bettel log zurück aber werden sie nicht machen
also kaum den server der nicht voll ist ist vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben
gesagt es gibt anstatt zwei surfer heute mal fünf surfer wo was los ist
was ist deine meinung zu sea of thieves habe ich nie gespielt ok stop ist doch ein bisschen
mehr bettel log hat gesagt heute ist aber echt erstaunlich voll in battlefield 3 scharkey
non stop 24 sieben kann man ohne probleme auch mit 64 mann spielen vielleicht sollten
wir nachher noch eine runde battlefield spielen
ich habe aber schon wieder jetzt ein paar letzten zwei drei wochen immer so was haben
die hier scharkey non stop das gefällt mir schon mal markiere ich mir schon mal für
später metro only no explosives ne ne danke danke das muss nicht sein
non stop tdm 24 wird immer schlimmer im prinzip sind auch nicht viel mehr selber voll als
sonst so der peter hainz ist am start
half life 3 ganz sicher ganz sicher ganz sicher mit sicherheit half life 3 auf der xbox bezester
was sonst also wo würde man es nicht am ehesten erwarten als dort
chat cute jawoll der hat ahnung der weiß gucken ob die die wichtigen wichtigen emotes
hier aktiviert haben nein haben sie nicht die sacken
noch nicht mal keckw aktiviert in battlefield 4 ist wirklich mega viel los ok zeig mal her
jetzt gucken wir uns jetzt an bf 4 hallo was ist so viel los dass es leckt
lack lack as fuck so hop refresh please man muss ja immer hier machen weil das ist sonst
nicht checkt übelste warte schla... ey da ist es ist ok
ok ja es ist ein bisschen mehr los als in battlefield 3 ist schon ganz ordentlich was
los kannst du dich nicht beschweren ok ich hab keine ahnung was in dem stream abgeht
ich weiß nur dass es in 5 minuten xbox stells los geht
so ich hab noch keine gescheiten predictions gefunden what what to expect ok also was was
wird hier predicted fable 4 juckt mich nicht elder scrolls 6 das glaube ich nicht ich glaube
ganz ehrlich mittlerweile das spiel ist noch nicht mal in entwicklung ich glaube die haben
einfach nur nen titelbildschirm gezeigt und äh und äh dings wie wie wie wie geht wie
geht das ähm wie wie wie geht die elder scrolls melodie noch mal
irgendwie so ähm die haben ja nur den nur den titelbildschirm äh gezeigt mit elder
scrolls melodie fertig
irgendwie so klingt das so und ich glaube das ist gar nicht in entwicklung die die
die tschüben die tschübenen uns einfach hart was ist das für eigentlich ein für ein unglaublich
diverser stream den ich mir hier angucke man könnte ja fast denken es gibt nur gamer grills
offensichtlich natürlich ja only so was wird denn was wird denn hier predicted halo stimmt
die müssen das neue halo mal zeigen guck mal chat was so ah die copypasta hilfe die copypasta
geht wieder geht wieder ei ei ei die wollen es wieder wissen so in fünf minuten müsste
aber eigentlich losgehen geht ja noch nicht los ich glaube nicht dass das hier die die
show ist also es soll angeblich in fünf minuten losgehen so xbox guck mal auf twitter da ich
auch auf dem richtigen stream bin nee man darf man darf dass die haben die haben gesagt
man darf streamen ja ja man darf streamen und wenn man von dem twitch gaming channel
restreamt ist noch besser weil dann pländen sie sogar copyright musik aus so also was
was was was gibt es denn hier halo ja was sonst irgendwie elder scrolls stellt bin ich
mal gespannt ob wie gesagt ich glaube immer noch dass es debate dass es in überhaupt
in entwicklung ist max a 690 dankeschön für den sub vier monate huge subscription hier
massive big big brain subs starfield mich auch nicht so gut microsoft focus 2001 20
jahre xbox who care wie das war es ist ja mal unglaublich spannend was da auf uns zukommt
ok die dati können da können sie mich ja nur noch überraschen jetzt so leute vier minuten
auf auf auf auf soll das ihnen halo sein super unlikely ok das ist immer noch pre show
guck mal sogar kronk ist am start das ist woodface was warum hat er warum kann er sich
das schon angucken nee das ist was anderes oder das ist woodface wie heißt er denn noch
mal mendes menendez melendez wie heißt moment woodface real name alex mendes genau so golden
boy genau woodface woodface 123 ok auf genug pre show jetzt auf gehts jetzt zeigt mal was
jetzt zeigt mal was also halo auf jeden fall da bin ich mir sicher also wenn die nicht
halo zeigen wer fail kann man die auflösung hochstellen ob jetzt jetzt in zwei minuten
oh nein oh nein habt ihr ihn gesehen wie viel größer mit fallout 76 11 mal größer ich
habe schon wieder vergessen zehnmal größer viermal größer ich weiß gar nicht was er
erzählt hat ich habe mir nur gemerkt dass er dummes zeug gelabert hat ok sag mal das
ist noch nicht das ist es noch nicht das ist es nicht es sollte jetzt eigentlich los
xbox Bethesda poggers genau mal gucken leg los Phil Spencer also ich mag Phil Spencer deutlich
mehr als den davor davor war es irgendwie don don don metric den metric oder so ok ich
habe keine ahnung ob die noch irgendwie zu potte kommen hier guck mal mal wie es bei
xbox aussieht ok geht noch nicht los dubstep wupp wupp wupp jawoll ja aber ich will nicht
vom xbox channel restream weil weil die haben extra geschrieben wenn man über den offiziellen
twitch gaming kanal restreamt dann muten sie etwaige copyright musik also das ist eigentlich
richtig richtig big brain von wohl restream piz mit denn von youtube von youtube xbox ok
easy wenn die das machen dann mache ich das auch lull von den profis lernen ja so jetzt
ernsthaft wollen die mich verarschen audio description ernsthaft kmbet bamm jetzt schreckt
der trick funktioniert immer noch so geil habt ihr es gesehen ist der beste ist der
beste trick überhaupt da funktioniert immer
eckermann ja was hast du gemacht ich habe die url geändert ah ok jetzt können wir
die sind schneller die sind schneller lull youtube bamm auf gehts das ist ja mega verstörende
hektische musik ja chain lore kannst du machen aber du musst uns das nicht unbedingt mitteilen
so auf gehts postchamp
ne oder was auch immer 18 Leute ihr wisst ne ausweiskontrolle anzeige ist raus
muss mal kurz gucken wie lautstärke ist ticken lauter können wir glaube ich machen ok wir
müssen erst mal gucken wie das abgemischt ist also es kann es kann durchaus sein dass
die abmischung mal wieder richtig sagt bamm dann zeige ja
so
Games mean to all of us, and I think you know this past year. They've met even more
Thank you for being with us today
Thank you for the support you give us and one another also im Ernst bei ihm noch irgendwas glaubt, der ist nie mehr zu retten
And I wouldn't be here if it wasn't for the friendships. We've had that whole time
At Bethesda we believe video games do one thing better than anything else they transport us
Through art and technology
There's real magic in a new world and can make it your own
We've traveled the worlds of Elder Scrolls of fallout
And now for the first time in over 25 years, we're creating a new universe
Das ist der Bethesda Chef
Set hundreds of years in our future. It's an epic about hope, our shared humanity and answering our greatest mystery
It's a game we've dreamt of playing. It wasn't told now that we have the hardware, the technology and the team
Who's hard at work at home to make that dream a reality?
We're excited to finally share our first in-game teaser and something to look forward to
Ich hab mich null verfolgt das Game. Kein Plassen Schimmer. Ich weiß noch nicht mal was das ist, überhaupt. It's Skyrim
Okay, sie haben nicht Fallout Serpentine 6 hingeschrieben
Na das ist ja blöd sind 25 Jahre in Entwicklung. Ach Chat Overlay, Moment, Moment, Moment
Ihr fängt ein bißchen wie Anthem an.roc
Sie sagen, das Wunder ist, nicht, dass das Feld von Staunen so groß ist, aber dass wir es getestet haben.
Du bist jetzt ein Teil der Konstellation. Ein Teil unserer Familie.
Was du gefunden hast, ist das Schlüssel, um alles zu entlocken.
Wir haben die Konstellation erreicht.
Das ist alles, worauf wir gearbeitet haben.
Wir sind am Anfang der letzten Reise der Menschheit.
Bereit für die Entfernung.
Wir müssen die Weltraumstelle verlassen.
Dein Wagen ist leer.
Deshalb sind wir hier.
Die Maschinen gehen.
Um zu entdecken, was da draußen ist.
Glückwunsch, Konstellation. Du bist so großartig.
Und jetzt?
Das war jetzt aber sehr aussagekräftig.
Oh, jetzt kommen sie wieder mit ihrer World Premiere Ansage.
Das machen sie jedes Jahr gerne.
Es ist toll, mit dir einen der weltweit am meisten erwarteten Spiele zu teilen.
Von Todd Howard und seinem Team.
Und ja, es ist exklusiv.
Willkommen zu der Xbox und Bethesda Game Showcase.
Ich bin so erfreut und stolz darauf, heute hier zu sein, um Spiele zu feiern.
Auch wenn es ein sehr schweres Jahr gewesen ist, bin ich dankbar, dass Spiele eine so wichtige Grundlage für Freude und Verbindung waren.
Wir sind erfreut, die nächste Ära der Gaming zu fordern.
Die Welt, die niemals möglich war, zu konjurieren.
Das Spiel über alle Geräte zu entlocken.
Und die Macht der Spiele für alle zu erfreuen.
Und jetzt?
Nicht nur als Partner, sondern als ein Team.
Einheit und die besten Spiele zu mehr Leuten überall zu bringen.
Also heute werden wir mehr von dem, was kommt.
Wir haben eine tolle Show.
30 Titel, 27 Xbox Game Pass.
Und natürlich, jede einzelne Konsole-Titel, die du heute siehst, ist optimiert für Xbox, Series X und S.
Offering Next-Gen-Performance.
Wir arbeiten mit den besten Studios auf der Erde.
Nächstes ist etwas, das wirklich beeindruckend ist.
Die neuesten Entritte in den Hauntings in einer Valkyrie-Franchise, die von GSC Game World gemacht wurde.
Stalker 2.
Zuerst kommen Xbox-Series-Konsolen und PC.
Das wird eine echte Next-Gen-Performance mit 4K-Resolution.
Ich bin echt gespannt drauf.
Es war ein schöner MP5 am Start.
Loot-Stalls, Aufsatz-Stalls.
So wirklich mit dem ersten Stalker zu tun hat, ist nichts mehr, oder?
Also es sieht überhaupt nicht nach dem ersten Stalker.
Aber das erste Stalker ist ja auch schon sehr alt oder so.
Als nächstes kommt dann das Stalker-Metro-Crossover oder so.
Nee, nee, das ist ein neuer Stalker.
Es könnte aber auch ein Metro sein.
Auf jeden Fall kein Comrade-Game.
Das ist klar.
M-C-A.
Ak-74U-Stalls.
Nee.
Sieht aber so aus, aber ist eher ne Shotgun, oder?
Gab schon einen Battlefield-Trailer, ihr müsst jetzt kommen gleich.
Er sieht schon recht hübsch aus.
Muss man ihn mal lassen?
Alles klar.
Ich hab gesehen die NDA für den Battlefield-Trailer ist schon um.
Heck wait.
Ach nee.
20.30 Uhr ist die erst um.
Stelsa.
Jawoll.
Ja, da bin ich echt mal gespannt drauf.
Ich kann mich an das erste Stalker gar nicht mehr richtig erinnern, solange ist das her.
Das Game ist ja auch schon Kano, 50 Jahre alt oder so.
Wann kam das erste Stalker raus?
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Oh, nicht noch mehr Zombie-Stalls.
Das erste Stalker kam 2010.
Nee, das kann nicht sein.
Das ist zu spät.
2007, ja.
Angeblich haben die jegliche Musik lizenziert für Restream.
Ist das dieses Ding von die, die auch Left 4 Dead gemacht haben, die jetzt ein extra Spiel
macht?
Ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt.
Aber ich seh es gleich, wenn ich den Titel sehe.
Stand da, hab ich nicht geguckt.
Ich hab geguckt, von wann Stalker ist.
Back 4 Blood, ja genau, das mein ich.
Das mein ich.
Die Zombie-Zeit ist halt irgendwie schon ein bisschen die Luft raus.
Ja, das meinte ich.
Aber die Zombie, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber aus dieser ganzen Zombie-Thematik
ist irgendwie die Luft raus.
Xbox-Exklusiv, okay, das kann schon mal nicht Battlefield sein.
Ist das nicht ein bisschen laut?
Nee, passt.
Ach, das maar wieder.
Was?
Das gibt's ja noch, das hab ich ja schon ganz vergessen.
Battlefield kommt jetzt gleich.
Okay, das muss ja irgendein DLT oder ein Addon oder irgendwas sein.
Oh nein!
Was?
Was anderes ist Ihnen nicht eingefallen, oder?
Was anderes ist Ihnen echt nicht eingefallen?
Okay, ich weiß nicht, ob das... Gibt es irgendeinen Sea of Thieves Spieler, der gesagt hat, er wollte einen Pirates of the Caribbean Crossover?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab das Spiel nicht gespielt.
Ich find's irgendwie wahnsinnig unkreativ, so ein... Egal, jeder, jeder wie Remarque.
Also mich wird's definitiv nicht dazu bringen, das Spiel zu spielen, aber wer es spielt und wer da Bock drauf hat, meinetwegen, ich sag nix dagegen.
Ich will es als Mario reinzumachen, ja okay, es hat mir nicht thematisch noch was mit zu tun, aber nicht viel besser.
Ajajaja Time.
Was hab ich bei Dan's Gaming gesehen? Das hat mich verwirrt, das Game.
Der Battlefield Trailer müsste jetzt eigentlich kommen, ich warte ja auch drauf.
Wie gesagt, ich hab das Main Game bei Dan's Gaming gesehen, das hat mich hardcore verwirrt, was ich da gesehen hab, das ging da schon die ganze Zeit so.
Ah, ah, ah, Battlefield, Battlefield.
Vierer Squads, Vierer Squads, Vierer Squads.
Also so wie das definitiv nie in irgendeiner Runde laufen wird.
Crabble, jawoll.
Tank Drop, wo immer noch keiner genau weiß, was man machen muss, damit man die droppen kann.
Gleich kommt auch noch ein bisschen was aus der Ego Perspektive.
Guckt, da seht ihr, dass ihr die Waffe direkt, was wir auch erzählt haben beim Reveal Trailer, direkt innerhalb des Gameplays anpassen kann.
Ja, die Zip-Lines haben sie angeblich auch auf allen möglichen Maps verteilt, dass man sich besser bewegen kann.
Das haben sie auch extra erzählt, nochmal.
Das ist, ich glaube, das ist wirklich exakt der gleiche Trailer, den ich auch gesehen hab.
Da kommen auf jeden Fall noch Ego Perspektive jetzt.
Ah, jetzt, jetzt.
Ah, jetzt, genau, genau.
Da sieht das schon aus, ne? Kannste nix sagen.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht der Trailer, den sie uns gezeigt haben.
Ich, da fehlen ein paar Sachen.
Den Trailer, den sie uns gezeigt haben, da war noch Infanterie-Gameplay, ein paar Sekunden Infanterie-Gameplay aus der Städte-Map dabei.
Und da hab ich zum Lost noch gesagt, da hab ich zum Lost damals noch gesagt, findest nicht auch, dass das ein bisschen vom Treffer-Feedback aussieht, wie Warzone, aber gut.
Aber ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, ich bin mir jetzt nicht mehr sicher.
Was ist das?
Was auch immer.
Das sind so nichts sagende Trailer, die könnte man sich auch immer sparen.
Die Systemvoraussetzungen werden nicht so krass sein, denke ich.
Wenn du jetzt in den PC hast, wo Battlefield 5 draufläuft, wird Battlefield 2042 wahrscheinlich auch halbwegs brauchbar drauflaufen.
Ich bin bereit für alles.
Zeit für Recht!
Der Schicksal des freien Denken-Wirbels ist in deinen Händen.
Warte mal ab, bis man da spielen kann.
Gibt ja wieder Beta, also Beta.
Promotion Beta.
Battlefield war gerade ja.
Vielleicht kommt noch was, vielleicht kommt noch was.
Die Zeit, wo Games rausgekommen sind, die nicht liefen, so zu Zeiten von beispielsweise Crysis 1, sind vorbei.
Sag Games, die heute rauskommen, die laufen teilweise auf PCs von vor 5-6 Jahren.
Easy.
Peter Heinz am Start, nice.
Okay.
Kein Battlefield, kein Battlefield.
Wie sie da immer von Familie sprechen, ich mein...
Na gut, zum Glück sagen sie nicht Freunde.
Bis der Freunde kann man sich aussuchen, Familie aber nicht.
Es wäre ja auch hart, wenn sie uns nochmal 60 Euro abknöpfen.
Skyrim.
2021 Skyrim.
Das ist 2021, Alter.
Ist das Spiel mittlerweile spielbar?
Nein.
Aber es ist ein Spiel aus 76, ja.
Hat das noch Spieler?
Wahrscheinlich hat das noch Spieler, sonst würden sie das ja nicht machen.
Cross-Gen in Battlefield, ja.
Du kannst auf alter und neuer Plattform spielen, mit dem gleichen Account.
Einmal dein Profil umziehen.
Der Fallout 76.
Das war mal so die richtige Totgeburt an Game, ey.
Zu Cross-Play in Battlefield weiß man offiziell noch nichts.
Ich such mal kurz Player-Account.
Angeblich spielen das noch 7000 Leute.
Fallout 76.
Täglich.
Also das ist gar nicht mal so wenig, aber auch jetzt nicht brutal viel.
Aber ich werde jetzt wegen dem Trailer definitiv nicht anfangen und Fallout 76 spielen.
Was kommt jetzt Fallout 77, oder?
Es könnte schon ein Fallout sein.
Fallout 2042.
Okay, das ist irgendein Addon für alles da.
Ja, das stimmt ja nicht, das sind 18 Millionen Accounts, die irgendwann mal angelegt wurden.
Also das habe ich auch gelesen, das ist angeblich das beste MMO für Solospieler.
So bescheuert es jetzt klingt, wenn man MMOs für Solospielen will, keine Ahnung.
Habe ich gelesen, keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
Ich habe nur mal die Beta gespielt, die war unfertig.
Ziemlich unfertig.
Das Spiel muss halt brutal einfach sein.
Die ganze Kampagne, das muss alles übelst einfach sein, sodass es jeder Kerl schon hinkriegt.
Aber cooles Soundtrack, Hamse.
Aber auch so hat Elder Scrolls Online einen coolen Soundtrack.
Müssen wir auf YouTube gucken.
Also das ist nice.
Ich spiele es nicht, aber der Soundtrack ist gut.
Was ist jetzt neu?
Epischer Soundtrack und Dinger.
Das sieht schlecht aus.
Ok, es ist doch nicht das, wonach es aussieht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, am Anfang sah es wie so eine billige World of Warships-Geschichte aus.
Und was bin ich sehend?
Was bin ich sehend?
Warum kloppt man sich da Stofftiere mit einer Klobürste?
Ist das so was wie Fall Guys plus mit niedlichen Tierchen?
Es hat irgendwie was von Fall Guys.
Party Animals.
Dazu braucht man Freunde.
Das ist Hades.
Oder Hades, wie die Amis das sagen.
Hades ist das.
Das soll richtig, richtig gut sein.
Also das soll ein richtig geiles Game sein.
Ich habe es mir auf Steam gekauft, davon habe ich noch nie gespielt.
Aber alles, was ich höre, soll richtig, richtig gut sein.
Und jetzt?
Es kommt auch auf der Xbox.
Ich hätte fast vermutet, es gibt schon auf der Xbox, aber anscheinend nicht.
Nee, FIPS habe ich nicht.
Aber es ist ein richtig geiles Game.
Okay, das ist wieder ein furchtbar nicht zahmender Trailer.
Der TF, warum schießen da Leute mit Laserstells rum?
Pass auf und jetzt kommt Werbung.
Schau hin, was deine Kinder machen.
Nein, ist was anderes.
Okay.
Und Papa landet im Knast, wenn er Raub kopiert.
Ich bin zu吓inn.
buzzing
Cross-Player Xbox-PC.
Ja, Halo hat ein bisschen abgebaut die letzten Jahre über.
Ich frage mich halt, wie sie das in der Halo Story noch immer erklären wollen, dass immer
wieder irgendwelche Halo-Ringe auftauchen.
In Halo 1 war das der einzige, in Halo 3 gab es noch einen und dann gibt es jetzt...
Wo kommen die alle her?
Ich hoffe Cortana ist wieder normal im Kopf in dem Teil.
Wenigstens haben sie wieder den gleichen Sprecher.
Der Master Chief Sprecher ist Proc und der Multiplayer Announcer ist auch Proc.
Cortana ist auch am Start.
Ich finde es auch geil, Cortana sieht in jedem Game anders aus.
Ach, das ist nicht Cortana, das ist Fake-Cortana, okay.
Stopp, Cortana.
Die Mission?
Die Mission wird geändert.
Sie werden immer geändert.
Bist du sicher?
Natürlich kann man kein Halo-Spiel ohne Multiplayer haben.
Und bei Xbox Series X kannst du auf 120 Frames pro Sekunde Infinite-Multiplayer-Aktion genießen.
Endlich bin ich sehr glücklich, dass Halo-Infinite's 1.
Free-to-Play-Multiplayer-Saison
auf der letzten Konsolengeneration haben sie immer erzählt, 60 FPS ist total overrated und jetzt haben sie die Möglichkeit und jetzt fangen sie mit 120 an.
Die haben eine 180 Grad Kehrtwende gemacht.
Davon lohnt es sich nicht, jetzt ist es das beste überhaupt.
Jetzt haben wir einen Halo-Hulk-Crappling-Hulk am Start.
Habt ihr den Ansager wieder?
Jawoll!
Der Halo-Ansager ist das beste.
Ja, das ist auch wieder der gleiche.
Kill him Manjaro!
Und leider ist so klassischer Fast-paced-Arena-Deathmatch-Multiplayer nicht mehr angesagt 2021.
Was kommt als nächstes? Halo Battle Royale?
Bloß nicht.
Es braucht nicht alles in Battle Royale.
Wenn es kostenlos ist, dann werden es sicherlich ein paar Spiele, je nachdem wie das drumherum gemacht ist.
Schreckt!
Okay, Free to Play ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Sache.
Free to Play ist eine gute Sache, das wird den Spielerzahlen sicherlich gut tun.
Mal gucken, wie sie das Ganze dann finanzieren.
Da kommt dann garantiert noch irgendwas.
Das hat bestimmt einen Haken.
Spoda!
Ist das Diablo 4?
Ja, muss Diablo 4 sein.
Nee, Diablo 2 Remastered ist das.
Das ist Marios Stell, das ist Diablo 2.
Also das muss eigentlich ein Diablo 2 Remake sein.
Muss das Diablo 2 Remake sein?
Kannst du mir erklären, was ein Halo Ring ist? Lies doch mal die Story von Halo.
Dann findest du das.
Ich kann jetzt nicht die Halo Story hier erklären.
Okay, Moment, das haben wir doch schon mal gesehen.
Das ist doch nichts Neues.
Okay, das mit dem Pala ist neu.
Ich muss sagen, sie haben es ganz gut gemacht.
Es sieht immer noch im Geiste des Originals aus, aber deutlich schärfer.
Das finde ich schon mal ganz gut.
Easy Mode mit Fisto Run.
Man erkennt noch, dass es ein Remastered ist.
Das finde ich echt nice, dass man das Geiste vom Original noch erkennt.
Was kommt jetzt?
Das finde ich echt so leckt.
Ist das Baldur's Gate 3? Nein, ist es nicht.
Was ist das?
Alter, das liegt nicht an mir, Leute.
Ich bin es nicht.
Guck, der Stream ist F.
Ach, das ist...
Moment, ist das nicht dieses Adventure?
Dieser Walking Simulator? Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Nee, das war es anderes.
Das war es anderes.
Oder?
Das habe ich auf Steam gekauft, wenn es das ist, was ich denke.
Ja, das habe ich auf Steam gekauft vor einem Jahr oder so.
Also das Originale. Das ist anscheinend jetzt neu.
Zweiter Teil, Stels.
Genau.
Far Cry?
Ist das der Typ aus Breaking Bad?
Muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich habe Breaking Bad nicht geguckt.
Ich kenne nur ein paar Ausschnitte und da ist mir der Typ in den Händen rumgeblieben.
Stels, genau bei eins.
Weil es dem Trend ist, Schauspieler, also echte Gesichter, Schauspieler in Games zu haben seit ein paar Jahren schon.
Leute, was nehmt ihr als Haustier? Den Hund oder das Kokodil?
You wanna blow shit up? Juan Cortez at your service.
Den Dackel? Okay.
Die Legehände ist auch da.
Erstmal M-Completten.
Ich glaube, das könnte echt ganz cool werden.
Wo ich ein bisschen Bedenken habe, ist, wie viel Raum dieses Crafting und Waffengehen kaputt einnimmt.
Weil da habe ich echt keinen Bock drauf, dass ich eine coole Waffe habe, die nach dreimal im Arsch ist.
Und dann wieder irgendwelche Crafting-Teile sammeln muss.
Aber das war in Far Cry 3 schon echt okay.
In Far Cry 6 gehen die Waffen kaputt.
Was ist das denn?
Game-Fooding-Cute-Chat.
Moshi Moshi running low on cuties.
Slime Rancher 2.
Ist das der zweite Teil von diesem Snowboard-Game, was es vor ein paar Jahren gegeben hat?
Oder ist das was Neues?
Weil das hat mich vor ein paar Jahren schon nicht gejuckt.
Ah, Step is Ubisoft. Ja, Sport-Games, wisst ihr ja, sind nicht so meins.
Nice Spuren.
Alles klar.
Hört sich ein bisschen an wie Lucio-Musik.
Das ist ein Mundfisch.
Was bin ich sehen wieder?
Was passiert gerade?
Bio-Schock auf Russisch.
Alles klar.
Ich meine, das sah jetzt zumindest irgendwie nochmal ganz interessant gemacht aus.
Kein Schimmer, was es uns sagen soll.
Aber immerhin, zumindest wird man nochmal ein zweites Mal hingucken.
Hi Raz.
Ich finde, das hat optisch was.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es uns sagen soll.
Aber das Game hat optisch was.
Oh.
Ich meine, es sieht äußerst stylisch aus.
Wahrscheinlich, dass es unter der Haube einfach ein Jump'n'Run.
2022, aha.
Okay, zumindest muss ich sagen, das hatte grafisch wenigstens was interessantes.
Zum Glück schenken sie sich dieses Mal dieses World Premiere, was sie sonst immer hatten.
Ach, das ist hier, ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt, aber das haben wir schon mal gesehen.
Ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt.
Das ist ein Game, das hatte auch schon beim ersten Mal einen coolen Trailer.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es ein gutes Game wird.
Weiß nicht, das ist eben so ein, oder zumindest nichts, was mich jetzt irgendwie begeistert.
Ach, das gibt's schon.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe das Release noch nicht mal mitbekommen.
Ich kann mich nur noch dran erinnern, dass wir den Trailer gesehen haben.
Ich habe mir damals auch schon gedacht, lustig gemacht, aber interessiert mich nicht.
Spoda!
Das ist ein Trains-Champ.
Was, das hatte mal eine Woche Hype auf Twitch?
Ja, die meisten Sachen haben mal eine Woche Hype auf Twitch, wenn sie rauskommen und dann ist es wieder vorbei.
Sus!
15 Player-Lobbys.
Okay.
Ah, das war es für unsere Anime-Fans hier.
Aber die können doch nicht mal in-Game was zeigen, die zeigen einfach Character-Artworks.
Oh doch, doch.
Das sieht cool aus.
Ich mag JRPGs.
Der Grafik-Style gefällt mir auch.
Aber ich spiele es wahrscheinlich trotzdem nicht.
Okay, das sieht jetzt aus wie ein schlechtes Handy-Game.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
2023?
The fuck?
Haben die sonst nichts zu zeigen?
Oh, ist das Cyberpunk?
Nein, das ist nicht Cyberpunk.
Das sah so aus wie Cyberpunk.
What the fuck?
Das liegt nicht an meinem Stream, das ist kaputt bei denen.
Oder es soll so sein.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das so sein soll oder ob das Stream einfach klitscht.
Jetzt nicht so die riesigen Schlager dabei gewesen bisher.
Neues Update, Microsoft-Flugsimulator.
Age of Empires?
Könnte das Age of Empires sein?
Oh, da bin ich jetzt gespannt.
Hoffentlich zeigen sie da ein bisschen mehr.
Das müsste Age of Empires sein, oder?
Warum sieht Age of Empires viel schlechter aus als Age of Empires 3?
Das ist jetzt In-Game-Grafik, das davor ist was anderes gewesen.
Okay, das stimmt nicht, das sieht deutlich besser aus als Age of Empires 3.
Vielleicht ist das ja auch gar nicht Age of Empires.
Doch, ist es.
Und wann soll das rauskommen?
Oktober 28.
Nice.
Meinen die das ja oder meinen die den 28. Oktober?
Man weiß ja nie.
We begin by hearing an old, wise sounding voice and we see a quiet, peaceful setting.
This will make our game seem big and important.
Now, something must break the serenity.
Will this creature be in the game?
Now, say goodbye to it forever.
And for no reason, people running.
These pointless slow motion shots make everything seem cool.
What does he want to tell us?
That war sound can mean only one thing.
Meta-Trailer.
Ja, das ist wie Radio-Werbung, die Werbung für Radio-Werbung machen.
In Wirklichkeit ist es FIFA 22.
Das ist der Titel.
Ja.
Ok, jetzt kommen wahrscheinlich noch irgendwelche Sport-Games oder so.
So Forza und hast du nicht gesehen.
Microsoft-Flug-Simulator und sonst was.
Wann gibt es denn eigentlich das Fly Simulator Forza Crossover?
Ich meine, eins muss man denen mal sagen, ihre Satelliten-Bilder zu In-Game-Geschichten, die sehen wirklich gut aus.
Das ist echt ein Game, wenn du da Fotos von machst, das kannst du auf den ersten Blick nicht mehr unterscheiden von Realität.
Das wird schick.
Das ist halt der Twitch-Chat.
Auf der Xbox, oder?
Jetzt kommt World of Warships oder irgend so ein Crap.
Oder World of Warplanes, oder?
Das ist nochmal Flug-Simulator.
Das ist das Top Gun Addon, das Top Gun Addon für Fly Simulator.
Tatsächlich.
Ich habe jetzt einfach nur ein bisschen blöd und es ist tatsächlich so.
Haben die sich irgendwie die Rechner dran gesichert und müssen jetzt gucken, was sie damit machen?
Unlimited Detail.
Ford Forza? Das ist ein Auto.
Oh, Rennspiele.
Rennspiele.
Die Landschaft sieht aber echt gut aus.
Ich muss euch mal ehrlich sagen, die Musik passt überhaupt nicht.
Ist das nicht Test Drive? Keine Ahnung.
Wenn ich bei Microsoft und Autos denke, denke ich immer an Forza. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die was anderes haben.
Jetzt auch auf Island mit Vulkanausbruch.
Wow.
RTX On sozusagen.
Wahrscheinlich macht Forza Horizon einfach mehr Geld als Motorsport.
Konferenz fertig. Beendet.
Das sieht besser aus als Crysis, Leute.
Komplett realitätslebensnahe Kommunikation.
Was macht man in Forza Horizon eigentlich? Also was ist das Ziel? Jetzt sagt nicht rumfahren.
Die Xbox-Series-Konsolen lassen uns alle letzten Details fangen. Die Szene sieht echt aus, aber es gibt keine Tricks. Das ist in-game.
Das ist ein perfekter Ort, um mit Freunden zu treffen und zu fahren.
Danke an die nächste Generation unserer Horizon-Live-Servicemen. Alle, die wir hier sehen, sind echte Spieler. Und es sieht so aus, als wäre Maddie mit anderen Mitgliedern der Forza-Team beteiligt worden.
Das ist ein Mural von mexikanischen Künstler Farid Rueda. Ein der vielen wunderschönen Teile Mexikos, die ihr über Forza Horizon 5 findet.
Das ist ein Mural von mexikanischen Künstler Farid Rueda.
Das Beste ist ja durch. Also die Landschaft sieht echt gut aus.
Starfield war schon ja und war total nichts zu sagen.
Der Chat lässt sich nicht jubeln.
12K! Ja für den Himmel hat 4K natürlich nicht ausgereicht.
Außerdem triggert mich 12K. Warum konnte man nicht gleich 16K nehmen?
Wir gehen jetzt tief in die Wälder, um Bill und die restlichen Spieler zu treffen. Hier sehen wir unser neues volumetrisches Lichtsystem, das die Szene füllen kann, als der Sonnenlicht durch die dünne Wälder fließt.
Forza Link weiß, dass Bill Mini-Games liebt, also er erläutert Sierra, um Bill zu besuchen. Bill akzeptiert es, und sie sind unabhängig zusammen mit ihrem GPS-Route-Set.
Die war Pinata. Viel der Fun, viel der Fun. Da könnten sie auch mal einen dritten Teil von machen.
Ja, davon gab es zwei Teile.
Das erinnert mich jetzt eher an Trackmania oder sowas.
Haben die jetzt eigentlich ein ordentliches Schadenmodell? Das wurde ja bei Forza immer angemeckert die letzten Jahre über, dass die Autos nicht richtig kaputt gehen.
Da ist er. Da ist er.
Komm, Phil, jetzt hau noch mal einen raus zum Schluss.
Kein Wort, du bringst zu Elder Scrolls 6?
Aha, doch. Wenigstens einmal erwähnt.
Wir in Deutschland wissen natürlich, dass man das Wolfenstein ausspricht und nicht Wolfenstein.
Ah.
Genau, zeig noch mal.
Das kann nicht Elder Scrolls 6 sein.
Battlefield wird schon gezeigt, ja.
Was ist das? Bibi und Tina?
Nee, doch nicht.
Ackerman Hood.
Sind das Zombies? Sind das ernsthaft wieder Zombies?
Das sieht so ein bisschen nach Hero Shooter mäßig auch aus.
Oder was?
Okay, es sind keine Zombies, es sind Vampire.
Das ist so eine Art Hero Shooter.
Okay, mal glücklicherweise keine Zombies.
Warum bauen eigentlich alle überall so komische Influencer Sidekicks mittlerweile ein?
Die gehen mir in echt schon auf den Sack. Brauche ich die jetzt im Game auch noch?
Okay, Zombies sind out, Vampire sind jetzt anscheinend angesagt.
Ich kann mir überhaupt keinen Reim drauf machen.
Koop, Hero Shooter mäßig. Es scheint eher PVM zu sein als PVP.
Mit dem Hund ab.
Das ist so ein bisschen die Ezio-Mütze von ihm.
Okay, ich kann mir null Reim drauf machen, was uns der Trailer sagen soll.
Es sieht aber eher nach PVM aus. Ist das vielleicht so eine Richtung Left 4 Dead?
Das hatten wir doch gerade schon. Okay, das ist das Outro Video jetzt.
Okay, also mal ganz im Ernst, so viel hat Xbox jetzt nicht zu bieten, wenn man nicht gerade Forza Fan ist.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich sagen soll, aber so eine komplette Knaller. Aber das meiste, was die gezeigt haben, war doch äußerst unspektakulär.
Stalker, ja. Aber das ist alles so Dinge, das hat ja mit Xbox nichts zu tun. Das kannst du auch mal auf dem PC spielen.
Genauso wie Diablo, genauso wie Far Cry. Also die ganzen Exklusivsachen haben mich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig vom Hocker gehauen.
Genau hier, er kennt sich aus hier. Duncansteinzz, PC Master Race, der weiß Bescheid.
Komm ich zu spät, hast du schon über Battlefield geredet? Ja, wir haben uns den Battlefield Gameplay Trailer angeguckt und wirklich viel zu sehen gab es ja nicht, habe ich heute Morgen schon gesagt.
Was sagst du zu Battlefield? Tja, was soll ich zu Battlefield sagen? Man hat in dem Battlefield Trailer jetzt nicht so viel gesehen, wo man mehr sagen könnte als das letzte Mal.
Kann man nicht generell alles von der Xbox auf dem PC spielen? Keine Ahnung. Die Strategie, das war die Strategie der letzten Jahre.
Also so krass geschockt hat mich davon jetzt nichts. Ich werde auf jeden Fall die Halo Kampagne spielen, das ist klar. Also Halo Kampagne werde ich spielen.
Und ansonsten das neue Age of Empires werde ich auf jeden Fall spielen. War nix, danke für den Sub. Ich muss mal übrigens gucken, habe ich jetzt alles hier übersehen gerade.
Guck mal, der Lost hat Battlefield 2042 eingestellt im Stream, BlackWade. Der macht große Analyse-Action, wie es aussieht.
Danke schon für die ganzen Subs Leute, den haben wir hier am Start. War nix, Kio Kone auch schon lange am Start, 22 Monate, Hyper Subscription hier.
PlayerCraftTV, Sorry for Bash, Maxi690, Sherlock Holz, Erwing, KingKraham und das andere schon heute Morgen. Chat wieder einblenden.
Tja, aber ansonsten hat es mich nicht so wahnsinnig geschockt. Ich gebe zu, ich bin ja da auch noch auf hoffnungsloser Fall. Es gibt nicht viel, was mich mehr schockt.
Sehr hoxin und Dankeschön für Hyper Subscription 22 Monate. Forza ist bestimmt cool für Leute, die so Rennspiele mögen. Wie? Wupp Wupp Wupp ist weg? Na denn.
Ah, jetzt. Der Android Soundtrack ist so nice entspannt. Was ist das für ein Anime Soundboard? Du meinst das hier? Oder meinst du das?
Das ist ein koreanischer Text-to-Speak-Engine. Es kommen noch andere Events, aber die werde ich nicht übergucken. Oder ich glaube, dass noch andere Events kommen, ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Aber die werde ich nicht übergucken. Wollten wir eigentlich nur den Battlefield-Trailer angucken, den Battlefield-Gameplay-Trailer? Fick dich weg, du homo-Fürst.
Genau. Fick dich weg, du homo-Fürst. Ah stimmt, die Nintendo Direct kommt ja noch irgendwann. Na ja, warten wir es mal ab. Es hat mich jetzt bei der Xbox technisch nicht so krass vom Hauen, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich glaube, das wird gar nicht so schlimm. Man darf nicht vergessen, 2042, das ist in 20 Jahren. Das geht schon. Da gibt es dann keine Jetpacks und keine Wallruns oder so.
Ich habe gehört, es soll auch demnächst Half-Life 3 kommen.
Na ja, Leute, ich bin jetzt nur angekommen, dass wir uns das zusammen angucken können. Ich werde jetzt schon wieder ausmachen. Ich habe nichts mehr geplant. Großartig. Auf den Titanfall 3 hätte ich auch mal richtig Bock.
Ich muss sagen, die Kampagne von Titanfall 2 war eines der besten Singleplayer-Kampagnen, die ich in den letzten Jahren gespielt habe. Nicht so sehr von der Story her, aber vom Gameplay war richtig gut.
Leider ist es nicht so gut angekommen. Runde BF, nee, zu spät. Boomer müde, Boomer bad. Ich habe ganz normales Windows 10 installiert.
Nee, habe ich nicht, habe ich nicht. Ich habe von denen nur Heavy Rain gespielt. Wie hieß das andere Game von denen noch, was die gemacht haben? Heavy Rain? Wie hieß das denn mit diesen Tentakel-Dingern da?
Wie hieß denn das andere Game noch, was die gemacht haben? War das Beyond Two Souls? Ja, das kann sein. Aber Heavy Rain war cool.
Leider, glaube ich, wenn man so ein Game von denen gespielt hat, die sind ja doch alle recht ähnlich, was ich gesehen habe, dann ist da auch die Luft raus. Ja, Titanfall 2 hat einen schlechten Release-Zeit, das stimmt.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns. Ich haue jetzt ab. Macht's gut, bis denn. See you.